en ningún momento de la noche de
elecciones el presidente de donald trump
fue declarado ganador y eso siempre que
tenerlo presencia el nunca llegó a la
cifra mágica de 270 él tenía una
inclinación de algunos estados que lo
favorecían electoralmente que puede
pasar pero a medida que hay que empezar
más llegar los votos en esa situación
podría cambiar qué fue lo que finalmente
sucedió
escuchaba en el día de ayer una
entrevista
del delegado estatal de pensilvania de
porque se habían demorado tanto y él
decía nosotros por ley tuvimos una
limitante nosotros sólo podíamos empezar
a contar los votos y a procesar los
votos en la mañana del día de elección y
hemos tenido que procesar más de un
millón de votos
únicamente una avalancha de votos que no
esperábamos y nuestras leyes estatales y
eso es algo que también estas son las
leyes estatales las que definen los
procedimientos y la manera en la cual se
procesan y se entrega la información y
ahí era claro que al final está
sucediendo en muchos estados
los demócratas votaron mayoritaria y
ampliamente por votación de correo que
pasa llega el voto el funcionario tiene
que mirar tiene que comprobar las firmas
sacar el voto procesarlo en la máquina y
después iba a ser contado es un proceso
dispendioso es un proceso difícil